you mentioned
that uh we should not necessarily be
at least to the degree that we are
worried about the existential risks of
artificial intelligence
relative to uh human
risks from human nature being
existential risk
what aspect of human nature worries you
the most in terms of the survival of the
human species
i mean i'm disappointed in humanity as
humans i mean all of us i'm one so i'm
at disappointed myself too
um it's kind of a sad state
there's two things that disappoint me
one is
how it's difficult for us to separate
our rational
component of ourselves from our
evolutionary heritage which is
you know not always pretty you know
rape is a is an evolutionary good
strategy
for reproduction murder can be at times
too
you know making other people miserable
at times is a good strategy for
reproduction it's just and it's just and
and so now that we know that
and yet we have to sort of you know you
and i can have this very rational
discussion talking about you know
intelligence and brains and life and so
on so
it seems like it's so hard it's just a
big transition to get
humans all humans to to make the
transition from be like let's
pay no attention to all that ugly stuff
over here
let's just focus on the institute what's
unique about humanity is our knowledge
and our
intellect but the fact that we're
striving is in itself amazing right
the fact that we're able to overcome
that part and
it seems like we are more and more
becoming successful overcoming that that
is the optimistic view and i agree with
you
yeah but i worry about it i'm not saying
i'm worrying about i think maybe i was
your question i still worry about it yes
um
you know we could be end tomorrow
because some terrorists could get
nuclear bombs and you know
blow us all up who knows right um the
other thing i think i'm disappointed
is uh and it's just i understand it it's
i guess you can't really be disappointed
it's just a fact
is that we're so prone to false beliefs
that we you know we have a model in our
head
the things we can interact with directly
physical objects
people that model is pretty good and we
can test it all the time
right i touch something i look at it i
talk to you see my model's correct
but so much of what we know is stuff i
can't directly
interact with i can't i don't know
because someone told me about it yeah
and so so we're prone inherently prone
to having false beliefs because if i'm
told something how am i going to know
it's right or wrong right
and so then we have the scientific
process which says
we are inherently flawed so the only way
we can
get closer to the truth is by looking
for
um contrary evidence yeah um like this
uh conspiracy theory this this theory
that scientists keep telling me about
that the earth is round
uh as far as i can tell when i look out
it looks pretty flat
yeah so yeah there is there's a tension
but it's also
um um i tend to believe that
we haven't figured out most of this
thing right
most of nature around us is a mystery
and so it
um but that doesn't work does that worry
you i mean it's like oh
that's that's like a pleasure more to
figure out right yeah that's exciting
but
i'm saying like there's going to be a
lot of quote unquote
wrong ideas i mean i've been thinking a
lot about
engineering systems like social networks
and so on
and i've been worried about censorship
and thinking through all that kind of
stuff because there's a lot of wrong
ideas there's a lot of
dangerous ideas but then i also read a
history
uh read history and see when you censor
ideas that are wrong
now this could be a small scale
censorship
like a young grad student who comes up
who like raises their hand and says
some crazy idea yes a form of censorship
could be
i shouldn't use the word censorship but
i think you may uh just like like
de-incentivize them from no no no no
this is the way it's been
yeah yeah you're you're a foolish kid
don't think yeah foolish uh
so in some sense uh
those wrong ideas most of the time end
up being
wrong but sometimes end up i agree with
you so i don't like the word censorship
um at the very end of the book i i i
ended up with a sort of a a plea or a
recommended course of action and
the best way i could i know how to deal
with this issue that you bring up
is if everybody understood it's part of
your
upbringing in life something about how
your brain works
that it builds a model of the world uh
how it works you know how basically it
builds that model the world and that the
model
is not the real world it's just a model
and it's never going to reflect the
entire world and it can be wrong
and it's easy to be wrong and here's all
the ways you can get the wrong model in
your head
right it's not prescribed what's right
or wrong
just understand that process if we all
understood the processes then i got
together and you say i disagree with you
jeff and i said lex i disagree with you
that
at least we understand that we're both
trying to model something
we both have different information which
leads to our different models
and therefore i shouldn't hold it
against you and you shouldn't hold it
against me
and we can at least agree that well what
can we look for in
its common ground to test our our
beliefs as opposed to so much
as we raise our kids on dogma which is
this is a fact and this is a fact and
these people are bad and and you know
where ever if everyone knew just to to
be skeptical of every belief and why
and how their brains do that i think we
might have a better world
do you think the human mind is able to
comprehend
reality so you talk about sort of this
creating models that are better and
better how close do you think we get to
uh to reality there's
so the wildest ideas is like donald
hoffman saying we're very far away from
reality
uh do you think we're getting close to
reality well i guess it depends on what
you define reality
uh we are getting we have a model of the
world that's very useful
right for basic well for our survival
and our the thing pleasure whatever
right
um so that's useful um it means really
useful oh we can build planes we can
build computers we can do these things
right
uh i don't think i i don't know the
answer that question um
i think that's part of the question
we're trying to figure out right like
you know obviously if you end up with a
theory of everything that
really is a theory of everything and all
of a sudden everything comes into play
and there's no room for something else
then you might feel like we have a good
model of the world yeah but if we have a
theory of everything and somehow
first of all you'll never be able to
really conclusively say it's a theory of
everything but say somehow
we are very damn sure it's the theory of
everything we understand
what happened at the big bang and how
just the entirety of the physical
process
i'm still not sure that gives us an
understanding of
uh the next many layers
of the hierarchy yeah abstractions that
form well also what if string theory
turns out to be true
and then you say well we have no reality
no modeling what's going on in those
other dimensions that are wrapped into
it on each other you're right
or or the multiverse you know i i
honestly don't know
how for us for human interaction for
ideas of intelligence
how it helps us to understand that we're
made up of vibrating strings that are
like 10 to the whatever times smaller
than us
yeah i don't you know you could probably
build better weapons and better rockets
but you're not going to be able to
understand intelligence i guess i guess
maybe better computers no you won't be
i think it's just more purely knowledge
you might lead to a better
understanding of the of the beginning of
the universe
right it might lead to a better
understanding of uh
i don't know i guess i think the
acquisition of knowledge has always been
one where
you you pursue it for its own pleasure
um and you don't always know what
is going to make a difference you're
pleasantly surprised by the the weird
things you find
you